a breath of the wild to voice actor has
caused fan speculation and the prince of
persia 2 remake is being made by a
different studio
pietro ubaldi the voice of daruk for the
italian dub of the legend of zelda
breath of the wild may have accidentally
revealed some new details for the
upcoming sequel in an interview with fan
site lego hyrule ubaldi revealed that he
had recorded new lines for breath of the
wild too returning not only for the role
of the rook but also as the goron
champion's ancestor this has led fans to
speculate that the ancestors of other
hyrulean champions could potentially be
encountered in breath of the wild too
although the jury is still out on if the
ancient heroes will be seen in
flashbacks or a completely different
time period altogether theories online
have pointed to breath of the wild 2
taking place millennia before the
original game allowing players to
experience the fall of ganondorf which
begins the cycle of a hero battling a
corrupted cannon that happens in every
game let me know what you want from
breath of the wild 2 or whatever it's
going to be called switching gears now
to another delayed game the prince of
persia the saiyans of time remake
ubisoft confirmed today that development
has shifted from ubisoft prune and
ubisoft mumbai to ubisoft montreal the
original creators of the sands of time
series whether or not the remake is
being rebooted or if ubisoft montreal
will continue working on what has
already been done is currently unknown
officially revealed during the september
2020 ubisoft forward event the prince of
persia remakes initial january 2021
launch date was delayed to march 2021.
two months later ubisoft announced that
the game had been delayed to an
unspecified date in the future so that
visuals combat and the new targeting
system could be further refined in the
comments let me know which one you think
is going to come out first breath of the
wild 2 or the prince of persia remake
and finally let's talk about what's out
today right now playstation plus
subscribers can grab this month's free
games fifa 22 curse of the dead gods and
tribes of midgard over on xbox and pc
halo fans can jump into the new season
of infinite multiplayer called lone
wolves this update brings a new battle
pass a shop refresh that should contain
brand new cosmetic items for spartans
their titles weapons and more when it
comes to modes lone wolves features the
new battle royale like mode last spartan
standing as well as king of the hill
land grab and elimination season 2 will
be fairly lengthy again with season 3
not set to begin until november and if
you're anything like me and sick of sifu
beating you down then you'll be happy to
know that the game has added the ability
to change the difficulty and if you
listen very closely you can hear all of
the twitter threads that are angry about
it
have you beat sifu yet let me know
because i'm about to i'll see you
tomorrow